>> Carley: LIVE IN WASHINGTON,
THANK YOU.
LET'S BRING IN SOUTH CAROLINA
CONGRESSMAN RALPH NORMAN, HAD A
CHANCE TO QUESTION THE SECRETARY
THIS WEEK.
CONGRESSMAN, GOOD MORNING TO
YOU.
TWO DAYS OF QUESTIONING, HE SAT
THROUGH THEM, YOU LISTENED TO IT
AND PARTICIPATED, AS WELL.
WHAT ARE YOUR TAKEAWAYS?
>> SECRETARY MAYORKAS IS A LIAR
WHO HAS CONTEMPT FOR THE
CONSTITUTION AND THE RULE OF LAW
AND TOTAL CONTEMPT FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
HOW HE CAN APPEAR AND LIE LIKE
HIEZ D
HIEZ -- HE'S DOING IS AMAZING TO
ME F. WE CONTROL THE SOUTHWEST
BORDER, HOW DO WE DEFINE
UNCONTROL? ED HE'S AN ELECTED
BUREAUCRAT DOING HARM TO THE
COUNTRY.
>> Todd: HE BLAMED TRUMP FOR IT.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> WE INHERITED A BROKEN AND
DISMANTLED SYSTEM THAT IS UNDER
STRAIN, NOT BUILT TO MANAGE THE
CURRENT LEVELS AND MIGRATORY
FLOW, ONLY CONGRESS CAN FIX
THIS.
>> Todd: IS THERE ANY EVIDENCE
CONGRESSMAN NORMAN, THAT THIS IS
TRUMP'S FAULT?
>> YOU KNOW, THIS FOLLOWS
PATTERN OF THIS ADMINISTRATION.
UNDER THE LAST 12 MONTHS OF THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION, 513,000
WERE APPREHENDED.
UNDER BIDEN ADMINISTRATION 2.3
MILLION, FIVE TIMES AS MUCH.
HE'S LYING AND HAS NO -- SUCH
DISREGARD FOR THE TRUTH.
FACTS DON'T LIE, THE EASIEST
THING TO DO IS CONTINUE TO BLAME
THE PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION.
IT IS SIMPLE, BUILD A WALL.
>> Carley: THAT IS SOMETHING
HE'S NOT GOING TO DO AND
ACTIVELY FIGHTING AGAINST.
IT IS NOW IN THE TEXAS NATIONAL
GUARD'S HANDS TO TRY TO BUILD
BORDER FENCING AND I BELIEVE
SOME IS GETTING DONE NOW.
WHAT IS THE END GOAL FOR
DEMOCRATS?
WE'RE TALKING 18,000 ILLEGAL
IMGRANTSS TRYING TO GET IN
EVERYDAY, WHICH WOULD OVER
BORDER PATROL.
WHAT IS THE END GOAL?
>> FOR THEM TO MAINTAIN POWER
AND GET REGISTRATION OF ALL
ILLEGALS AND HOPE AND PRAY THEY
VOTE FOR THE DEMOCRATS.
AGAIN, TOTAL DISREGARD AND YOU
LOOK AT SUCH NUMBERS AS WE'VE
NEVER SEEN.
THIS IS A TRAVESTY FOR THE
COUNTRY AND ONCE THEY ARE IN
THIS COUNTRY, HOW DO YOU GET
THEM OUT?
YOU DON'T.  END GAME IS TO
CONTROL POWER AND WE'LL CONTINUE
TO HIGHLIGHT IT AND MAKE HIM
COME BEFORE THE CAMERA AND TRY
TO EXPLAIN, BUT IT IS MORE LAWS.
>> Carley: CONGRESSMAN NORMAN,
IT APPEA